coué
bienvenue à une perle à la fois je me
présente michèle audette de la nation
innu et québécoise pour cette chronique
j'aimerais déposer une perle spéciale
pour notre guerrière duris et chaque
coin qui nous a quitté de façon tragique
en septembre dernier
j'aimerais aussi partager cette perle à
son conjoint carole et leurs enfants
bien sûr a dit à michel les parents à la
communauté de manouane et à cette belle
grande nation atikamekw
j'aimerais aussi partager une perle ou
premières nations métis et aux inuit qui
ont un moment donné dans leur portage de
vie étaient brimés dans leur droit à la
santé
oui la santé est reconnue ou considéré
comme un droit selon les normes
internationales des droits de la
personne
alors quand le droit à la santé est
compromis la sécurité en est grandement
affectée elle aussi alors
malheureusement si ce que jobs nous a
démontré à tous et à toutes
vous comprendrez que je chéris ces
petites perles qu'elles sont précieuses
et que j'essaie des angles paix d'unité
cheveux de l'amour que j'ai car en ce
moment la famille écoutent attentivement
tous les témoins qui passe devant la
coroner pendant les audiences publiques
pour nous la santé ou la définition de
la santé et surtout un une façon de voir
un grand ensemble une approche
holistique global dans lequel la
sécurité physique mental émotionnel et
spirituel et social font un tout ça veut
pas dire que quand il ya absence de
maladie
je suis en santé mais c'est plutôt quand
j'ai un équilibre à travers l'espère que
je vous ai nommé et là on peut parler de
santé globale les facteurs socio
économiques tels que l'emploi le
logement l'éducation le revenu
l'alimentation les ressources durables
ont là aussi une influence directe sur
ma santé et la santé de ma communauté
pendant leur quête nationale beaucoup de
témoignages nous permettent encore une
fois de corroborer que la pauvreté les
logements le manque de logements sur
pardon l'insécurité alimentaire et les
réalités socio économique va avoir un
effet direct va compromette même la
santé physique émotionnel et spirituel
des femmes et des filles autochtones
alors pour remédier à ça bien des gens
vont nous dire depuis des décennies
lorsque les solutions vient de la base
et que le reste autour on les a campagne
on les soutient et on n'impose pas bien
on peut voir des résultats
super intéressant est super important et
là c'est pour ça qu'il est important car
qu'on parle de mettre l'accent sur la
guérison des personnes des familles ou
des communautés
ben c'est important que les systèmes
participent à ce grand changement
on parle de système canadien on parle de
système québécois de marché et des
compagnies et surtout d'honorer le
principe de joyce alors je vous dirais
quelques paroles de ton hisser une
personne qui a partagé pendant la quête
nationale
des paroles qui m'ont touché qui m'ont
fait réfléchir et elle nous dit en tant
que survivant tu es membres de familles
ayant perdu avec
cher qu'elle va réaliser dans son
processus de guérison c'est que elle
commence et nous dit je commence à
comprendre qui je suis en tant que femme
issue d'une première nation que j'ai moi
aussi des cadeaux et que je suis un
cadeau en plus que je des cadeaux à
offrir
alors vous et moi quel serait le cadeau
que nous pourrions offrir à la famille
de dresser chaque coin et à toutes
des membres des communautés des nations
des métis et les inuits à travers le
canada